- She's no stranger to the military.
As I mentioned, her
step-father served our country
in the Air Force.
You know her as Psylocke
in "X-Men: Apocalypse",
and as a correspondent
on "The Daily Show".
Let's give it up for Olivia Munn!
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
Oh my God!
- Hello!
It's okay.
- I'm so good. You look so cute!
- You do too!
I was worried like, if I
should be wearing black or not.
- [Kelly] I was worried about colors, too.
So, I just went like, classy.
- [Olivia] It made me so happy
to see you just now in black.
- We went classy!
- Got the belts, got the black!
- Yes.
And the southern roots kicked
in with both of our belts.
(laughs)
It's awesome.
Well, it's nice to see you in person!
Like, I think we Zoomed
twice over the summer,
the summer session,
so we talked about X-Men, ninjas, puppies.
We covered the basis in the summer.
- [Olivia] That's basically everything
that I'm interested in.
- [Kelly] I know, me too.
But I didn't know that you
came from a military family.
- Yeah!
- That's amazing.
- You know, I was in a military family
my entire upbringing.
Being in the military is something that
is just such a huge part of my identity
and something that I'm very proud of.
- [Kelly] Is it at all usual
childhood stuff on a base
for flirting and like, first
kisses and all that stuff?
Or is it very like, oh my
God, I'm gonna get punished,
or like, is that the same
thing going on there?
Or is it like, way more strict?
- Were you punished for
having your first kiss?
- [Kelly] Oh, I never even wanted to.
I was like, ugh.
- [Olivia] That's how I was.
- And then you grow up with
them, so I'm kind of like,
I don't wanna kiss you!
Your little a brother.
- [Olivia] Well, 'cause you're from Texas,
so everybody's known each other from like,
kindergarten up, right?
- For a lot of mine.
For like, fourth grade
up for me, but yeah.
- [Olivia] So, like, that's
not how it was for me.
My first kiss actually was
when I was in eighth grade.
I was 13 and I had just
moved back to Japan,
and that's a tough age, right?
- Your first kiss was in Japan?
- Mm-hm.
- What a cool story!
(laughs) That's where it stops being cool.
That's the end of the
cool part of the story.
- [Kelly] My first kiss was horrible.
I was like, are you
searching for something?
- Oh my gosh!
- I was like, eugh!
It was the grossest thing ever,
and I was like, I'm never
doing it again. (laughs)
- Mine was just the biggest
social panic attack ever.
So, I had gone to the
new school at Dakota,
and there's this guy
named Daniel Carter, and,
- You know his full name still?
I love it!
- Oh my God, he was so cute.
He was so cute.
And I just really liked
him from the beginning,
and it was one of those, hey,
do you wanna go out with me?
Do you wanna go out with me?
And then we never talk again. You know?
Like, we're boyfriend and
girlfriend, but we never talk.
And then, one day, my
best friend, Corinne,
who's still my best friend, she was like,
"Hey, so, Daniel is gonna kiss you today."
I'm like, "What do you mean
he's gonna kiss me today?"
They're like, "Yeah, he's
gonna kiss you today,
and everybody knows."
And I remember I was,
- Oh, no!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I remember walking down the hall,
and everyone just kind of
looking at me and giggling and,
- [Kelly] Oh, that's horrible.
- It was the worst.
So, but I avoided Daniel all day long,
- (laughs) 'Cause that's what I would do.
- Naturally.
And it was the very, very end of the day,
and he's like, "Hey, can we talk?"
So we go out to the back of the school,
and right by the spot that we're at,
it was the stairwell and it's two story,
and the entire eighth
grade class was just,
their faces stuck up into these
windows, literally watching,
- Your first kiss was like a movie.
Everybody was watching it?
- [Olivia] Everybody was
watching, 'cause they'd
known all day long,
and then they knew we were
meeting there, and so,
- [Kelly] Was this like,
a peck or a French kiss?
- Well, it ended up being a really long
just like, kiss.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's even more awkward.
- Because what happened was he was,
we're standing there, and then
he's takes a step forward,
I take a step back.
(Kelly laughing)
He takes a step forward,
I take a step back,
and then we hear the bell for the bus,
and then it goes on, and
then he takes a step forward,
I take a step back,
and then we hear the
bell for the second bus.
He's like, "That's the late bus.
My mom's gonna kill me
if I don't make it,"
and I was like, "Okay."
I take a step back, I hit the wall.
He takes one step forward
and all the kids were there, watching,
and he just comes in, gives me a kiss,
and just holds for the longest time.
I remember looking over, like,
- [Kelly] Your eyes are open?
- Yeah. I was like,
I didn't know what to do!
I remember looking over,
and I just saw, like,
my best friend, Corinne,
just going like, in the
window, with everybody around.
- [Kelly] That is mortifying! Wow.
- Yeah. I had another kiss
until like, the next year.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh. Yeah,
I waited a long minute.
I was like, people be
searching for buried treasure
back in the back of my mouth.
I did not like it.
All right.
So, Olivia, there was a self
defense move that you posted.
So over the summer sessions, everybody,
I'm obsessed with self-defense
or any kind of ninja stuff,
and I wanna know it,
and I just don't have time to learn it,
but we're gonna make this happen,
but I wanna roll this footage real quick,
'cause it's amazing.
(Olivia grunts)
(Kelly yells)
Oh my gosh! Like, that is my best day.
That's my best day in
life if I can do that.
- That one's an easy
one I could teach you.
- That's an easy one?
- That is an easy one.
Like, so, I, right now, am
training for an action movie,
and this is Jeremy, my fight
trainer during this time.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, did you hurt Jeremy?
- [Olivia] No, 'cause
thankfully he knew how to fall,
but if someone's throwing a punch at you,
you just come back around
and you wrap your arms around their arm,
and then you use your whole body
to just fall with them.
- [Kelly] Okay, wait.
I've got a lot of weight to
throw on, so I'm into this.
(Kelly laughs) I'm like,
I can really do this.
- It doesn't hurt you at all.
You just, once you wrap
your arm around them,
So, if somebody's throwing a
punch, if you threw a punch,
and then I'm gonna come back,
- You come around this arm?
- And then I'll just spin my whole body,
and then you come over.
- I wanna take classes with you.
- [Olivia] I know! we'll do it!
And this team is the "John Wick" team.
- Oh! I love those films.
- And they're so great.
And the people there, they're amazing,
so there's so much you can learn there,
and your kids could learn, too.
- [Kelly] My kids are so into it.
They act like they're ninjas already.
Well, I think you're a total badass.
I keep telling you this.
You probably think it's
awkward at this point,
but last time you tried to
teach me some warrior moves,
remotely, but I didn't have any weaponry,
so, I do now.
Justin! Where's he
coming? Okay, here we go.
Here we go!
- Have you ever wielded a sword?
- [Kelly] I have never wielded a sword
'cause I'm not a knight.
(both laughing)
- Okay.
Well, a lot of the sword
maneuver is in the wrist, okay?
So you wanna be able to open your,
- [Kelly] So, you just open?
- That's good! Yeah.
- So, you use your thumb
to press it back up?
- Practice with your
hand, right here, first.
Right here, so it just looks
a little cooler, right?
And then you're gonna go,
- [Kelly] I'm kind of amazing at this!
(laughs)
- [Olivia] Okay, that's good.
And now we're gonna bring
it around the front.
- Oh my. Like this?
- You're bringing it around.
- Oh, okay. Okay, wait.
So this, and then, wait.
You're gonna chop your leg off.
- But you gotta move.
(Kelly screams)
You gotta move to,
- Woo!
Woo (beep)! (laughs)
- [Olivia] But if you go
slow, it goes like this.
You go like this, you bring it around,
- Okay.
Oh my God, but you're not going slow!
- Well, I did at first.
- Okay, wait.
If you're coming around
this way, how do you,
- Here. Okay. We go, one,
and then, so, from here,
- Yeah.
Oh, my sleeve.
Okay.
What?
- I'm not a good teacher.
- [Kelly] (laughs) But you're
badass and doing it, so, wait.
- You have to move your body to,
- Oh! Oh, I get what you're doing!
You're doing this. Okay, okay, okay.
So, you're doing,
Shoot! I'm gonna kill myself.
- Spread your legs a little bit more.
So, you wanna get in good
stance so that you're strong.
You're gonna go from here.
See how my body does this?
I'm bringing it around.
- [Kelly] Yeah, like that.
- A lot of martial arts, and
people who do martial arts,
understand that it's so much
in your twisting in your hips, you know?
- Oh, is this gonna be
all about your core?
'Cause, you know what?
That's not my thing.
- No, but you've got a great ass,
and it's all about your ass.
- Yes! (laughs)
I got a lot of that-ness.
- See, that's were you need!
It's been killing me.
I've been needing to like,
build up my thighs more,
'cause you can't be able to,
- I don't need to build up my thighs.
- You look at action movies.
You'll see a lot of people
who don't really know how to do stunts.
They haven't done a lot of the work to it.
They do a lot of stuff on the top,
and you can tell it doesn't
look as impressive, you know?
If you just do this, it's
not as impressive as like,
being able to come around with your body.
- Oh my God, you're so
cool. How you just did that.
- But you can do too!
- And you're like,
a supermodel, too, so it's
kinda like, way hotter.
Did I do it? Is it like
this, and then you, like,
- Yes!
- Okay!
- That's so good!
(Kelly yells)
Yes!
(Kelly yelling)
(audience cheering)
'Kay, you got this! Okay,
we'll do it together,
and one, two, three.
- Woo-sha!
Now we can be in a
superhero movie together.
- [Olivia] Yes! You
could be "John Wick 7".
- Exactly.
- That's huge!
- What's a girl named for that? (laughs)
- Jonah Hicks?
- Yeah, there we go.
Jonah Hicks, that's us.
- That was really good!
A lot of people have
a hard time with that.
- [Kelly] I kind of feel amazing
right now, but it's fine.